Brian Cutler of Brian Cutler On Camera Actors
Studio [Burbank, CA]: That was really good.
Who starts?
Jean Mora, Actor: I do.
Brian: Jeannie does
John Keating, Actor and Assistant at
Brian Cutler On Camera Actors Studio:
We are rolling, sound is
speeding, we have a mark, action!
Jean Mora, Actor: …You're not leaving?
Adam Dale Tucker, Actor: I have to go.
Jean: This is ridiculous! You…you sneak in
here unannounced, you drink all of my wine,
you [__] me, you leave me high and dry,
then you go to the bathroom for like half an
hour and then you saunter off through the dark
and you start getting dressed as if I wouldn't
notice and without any explanation. It's pretty
obvious that you go to your [__] dinner party!
Adam: Okay, come on don't get angry.
I told you I was going to the dinner
party last week. I reminded you about the
dinner party when I arrived this afternoon.
A couple hours ago you didn't seem
to mind. You were very welcoming.
Jean: I know but I…I changed my
mind okay. I changed my mind. I
mean especially since it's your
last night in LA and we’ve spend
hours together in bed. I mean normally we
have supper together and we cuddle and I just,
I just, I thought we were gonna do that
tonight Shane? I thought we were gonna do that?
Adam: Okay, well look, don’t…it's fine.
Don't make yourself feel guilty about anything
or anything like that okay I'm not mad.
Just…look it doesn't matter, Michelle. It
doesn’t, it doesn't matter, nothing matters okay?
Jean: It does matter, it
matters to me! I mean it's
pretty obvious after tonight that
something else is going on. It’s
obvious that you can't be with
me because there's another woman.
Adam: Oh my gosh. Okay…so
what does that prove?
Jean: You know, I think
you're a bastard for using me.
Adam: I haven't used you.
Jean: [Imitating Adam] “Oh I haven't
used you!” Yes you have and I think
Dave Hartley's a bastard too for not inviting
me to that stupid [__] dinner party too.
Adam: Okay, well he's not putting it on, Allison
Ridley is and she doesn't know you. She doesn't
know about our relationship. We both decided that
we'd have separate lives, separate friends and we
wouldn't become that perfect twosome okay.
Our relationship has never had any strings
because of you if I recall correctly yeah well I I
changed my mind okay I changed my mind Shane okay
look I love you Shane and I just I I I want to
go with you tonight and can I can I please just
no you can't not this late of hour it's a seated
dinner party okay so stop trying to make me feel
guilty of course of course I'm not involved in
your inner little circle and it makes me want to
puke all of you, the Heartleys, the O’Hare’s, the
O'Neills, all of them make me want to [__] puke.
You're so pretentious in your own little
[__] circle never allowing any outsiders ever
you with your old money you know you're never
allowing anybody but you guys you know I think
it is I think it's incestuous all you do is hang
out with your country club people and your Beverly
Hills mansions and you never allow anyone from the
outside it's sick I have to go I'm very late you
know I'm really sorry that this uh had it ended on
a bad note but there's nothing else to be said so
I really wish we could have
been friends though friends
hey your goddamn mind friends why don't you go
with that [__] right oh is she debutant part
of like a country club is that why you don't
bring around I bet you've got that dinner
you know there's one thing I don't understand
every single time you come crawling back to me
all hot and bothered and I accept you for what
what is it because she's so pure and virginial
that you you can't you can't you can't mess with
her because you're saving her for marriage and I'm
just the one that you [__] with or is it because
she's not falling for your charms is that it
great I'm sorry I am I I
didn't mean to speak out a term
I didn't mean to be cruel I just um
just really hoping that we could talk
I mean you know I love you I've loved
you since the first time I saw you
I didn't mean any of it
I just I I treasure every moment that we
have together and I I just thought bye.
Brian: And cut. That's a ton of dialogue girl
yeah that's all right nobody knows but you and
me we couldn't tell yeah nobody knows nobody knows
here's the thing to remember once you're in motion
you don't stop only the director says cut or the
DP they're the only people that say cut actors
don't cut a scene you know even William H Macy
doing his eighth or ninth season of Reckless
you know in the middle of a very
dramatic scene he went up on his lines
and he stopped he kept his attention and
focus on his partner because we know the
key to this whole thing is if you're doing
it correctly total concentration of attention
away from yourself is a creative source of
acting he stopped kept his concentration
said line please and he gave him the line he
backed up two lines and picked it up and they
keep going keep going the script coordinator will
make a note the director will make a note they'll
do a pickup shot don't you worry that's not your
you don't worry about that that's not your job
does their job don't try to take church out to
be mad you know you do your job okay so nobody
knows if you drop a line trust me I know you know
maybe your partner knows sometimes but not always
getting more comfortable
yeah I know it you're yeah
okay are we ready everybody's simmered ready
in the booth at least those on the animal
we are rolling sound is speeding we
have a mark whenever you're ready
you're not leaving I have to go so you come here
unannounced you drink all my wine you [__] me
you leave me high and dry and then you're just
out of here you go to the bathroom for about
half an hour and then you come out you change in
the dark expect me not to say anything not even to
notice it's pretty obvious you go in your [__]
dinner party right now okay don't be mad I told
you about the dinner party last week I reminded
you about the dinner party today when I arrived a
couple hours ago you did not care you were very
welcoming yeah but now I do care okay because
it's your last night in LA and I expect that we be
together especially after we spent several hours
together in bed I mean normally you give me supper
and and we cuddle in bed for a while okay I mean
like I am Shane I'm sorry I am I I didn't
want your last moments here to beat the whole
I just I I love you I'm sorry
I didn't mean to make you
make it I'm not mad okay and
there's nothing to be sorry for
so stop trying to make yourself feel guilty okay
it doesn't matter Michelle it doesn't matter
you know I think it does [__] matter
especially after this evening I think it's
pretty clear that the reason why you don't want
to be with me is because there's somebody else
okay and that proves what completely your [__]
[__] need me that you've been using me this
whole time I'm not using you you cannot use me
you're using me just like Dan Hardy I think he's a
[__] [__] because he's invite me to the dinner
party okay well he's not holding it Allison Ridley
is and she doesn't know you she doesn't know
about her relationship because we both decided
to keep everything everything separate Our lives
our friends we didn't become that perfect twosome
our relationship has never had any strings
because of you if I recall correctly
and besides you never liked my friends
until today so because it changed my mind
it's very nice it's your last night here I
and I just come with you to the dinner party
please no you can't you know you know that
not this late of an hour it's a seated dinner
party so stop trying to make me feel guilty
wow didn't your precious little circle I know all
of you guys make me want to vomit you the parties
are all villains you and your your precious
little Elite Circle never involving anyone
else but yourselves you're just a bunch of
rich snobs that's what you are all the money
so hateful of everybody else but your
own selves you think you're incestuous
just hanging out at your Beverly Hills mansions
and your country clubs never allowing any
Outsiders it's sick it's disgusting
yeah I have to go it's late okay I'm
I'm sorry this ended on a bad note
but there's nothing left to be said
and I I really wish we could have
been friends but friends friends
get out of here leave go with your [__]
girlfriend I know she's at that dinner party
go with her was she some debutante from some
country club some rich little family is that
why you don't want to bring her around there's
one thing I don't get why night after night
I'm the one you come crawling back to is it
because she's too precious to be deflowered
she's a virgin you don't want to ruin her before
marriage is it because you just bumped your [__]
games it doesn't fall for your charm and your
fancy clothes maybe she's more Rich than she there
I'm sorry
that was um cool
I am
I love you
I don't know I really want to spend
your last night together if you want me
I didn't mean to be cruel you know
I just the first time I saw you I
knew that you were the one for me.
Brian: And cut!
Give that girl a Prozac. [Round of applause from
the class] Yeah, good, good, good, good, good,
good work. Yeah all right bipolar/bipolar plus.
Okay Rochelle and Mr. Abner…[to be continued].